Over the weekend, Donald Trump's least intelligent
son that we are aware of.
That's Eric Trump made some completely ridiculous
and absolutely irresponsible comments.
He went on Fox News to the program of Judge
Jeanine Pirro and said just a series of wacky
things that were either lies or wrong.
He also alleged a number of baseless.
BRACA.
So let's dove right into the first clip here.
Seventy six days to be exact away and less
than five.
Biden loves this.
Biden can't go on stage without making some
horrible blunder.
I mean, even from his basement, he's making
awful gaffes every single day.
So his campaign is thrilled that he's not
going out there.
And they think they're taking away Donald
Trump's greatest tool, which is being able
to go into an arena and fill it with 50000
people every single time.
Right.
So they will.
So Trump was not filling arenas with 50000
people.
This seems to run in the family.
Either everybody in the Trump family is really
bad at estimating crowd size or everybody
in the Trump family is obsessed with lying
about crowd size.
And of course, Trump was doing plenty of rallies
and many different events, regularly lying
about the attendance, but he didn't have any
50000 person rallies.
And hilariously, when I tweeted about this,
someone said it was so predictable.
David, when he went to India, more than 50000
people came out to see him.
They came out for their prime minister and
half the crowd left when it was Trump's turn
to speak.
But if you're one example is from a different
country, then you know that you're failing.
But this is minor.
This is minor.
I want to focus on the big thing.
Here's the big lie, the big conspiracy from
Eric Trump.
And you watch Bill milk it every single day
between now and November 3rd.
And guess what?
After November 3rd, coronavirus will magically
all of a sudden go away and disappear and
everybody will be able reopen.
They're trying to deprive him of of his his
greatest asset, which is the fact that the
American people love him.
The fact that he's relatable, the fact that
he can go out there and draw massive crowds.
Joe Biden can't get 10 people in a room.
My father's getting 50000 in a room.
So he again mentions the 50000 person crowd
thing.
That's a lie.
But most importantly, Eric Trump says after
November 3rd, the virus will magically go
away.
He suggests that the entire global corona
virus pandemic is a hoax to keep Donald Trump
from having rallies.
Now, here is what's absolutely crazy about
this.
This is actually what Republicans did to Obama
with Ebola in 2014.
We had four cases of Ebola diagnosed in the
United States.
Two of those came from abroad.
We had two deaths, not two percent death.
We had two deaths from Ebola in the United
States.
And it was all meant to be an attack on Obama.
The day after the 2014 midterms.
Go back and check out my clips about this
at the time.
Republicans stop talking about Ebola altogether.
Now, the difference is that wasn't a global
pandemic.
This is.
And yet Eric Trump believes the day after
the election, this goes away.
Then Eric Trump wraps up his comment with
even more nonsense.
And they want to do everything they can to
stop it.
So make no mistake to a lot of them.
Geneen to a lot of them.
This is a very cognizant strategy that they're
trying to employees no different than, again,
the nonsense.
That was right.
Tried throwing the back.
It's no different than the mail in voting
that they wanted to.
All these places is no different than wanting
illegal immigrants to vote in our country.
It is a cognizant strategy and it's it's sad.
And again, it's not going be allowed to happen.
We're going to win November.
OK.
And then Trump goes on to say that reporters
wearing masks is also part of the conspiracy.
If this wasn't Trump's son, who you knew was
merely doing disinformation, propaganda, you
would question his mental state and his connection
to reality, given the wacky nature of what
he's saying.
Take a look.
If you look at the White House press conference
yesterday, they're all in there.
They're they're criticizing everybody.
Why isn't everybody wearing masks?
Why isn't it wearing masks?
All of a sudden, the press conference ends.
They continue to roll a clip and all the reporters
are ripping off their massan room and going
up to each other and speaking.
I mean, it's it's really insane.
I mean, they're furthering that.
They're actually stoking fear in this country.
They're doing a massive disservice.
They're being totally disingenuous about the
whole thing.
But they're doing it for one reason.
They want to hurt Trump.
They tried to do it with a Russia thing.
They tried to do it with, you know, the Ukraine
scandal.
They tried to do it with impeachment.
Now they're trying to do it with Corona virus.
They know they can't beat him.
They know that Joe Biden can't beat him.
He doesn't he doesn't stand a chance.
So what are they trying?
They're they're trying to do anything that
they can't stop him.
They'll shut down the economy.
They'll stop in-person voting.
So there it is, evidence that this is a totally
fake bogus hoax political scandal, that after
a press briefing, reporters removed their
masks.
Real smoking gun you've got there, Eric.
Now, let me go back for a moment to it'll
be over by November 3rd because it's a hoax.
I already told you this is what happened in
2014 with Ebola.
You don't even need to go back to 2014, though.
Go back to the 2018 midterms and that caravan
of dangerous criminal illegal immigrants that
we're going to come here and kill and sexually
assault people back in 2018.
The midterms went by.
You didn't hear about it again.
This is the utmost projection.
Democrats haven't created the Corona virus
hoax to hurt Trump.
It's a global pandemic.
Republicans really did turn Ebola, which was
a few localized outbreaks into a political
weapon against Barack Obama.
Republicans really did turn the immigrant
caravan, which posed no threat or challenge
to our law enforcement at all in 2018 into
fear mongering to help Republicans in the
midterms.
They do that which they accuse Democrats of
doing.
It's called projection and Eric Trump.
Sadly, he's just not as good as Donald Trump
junior at convincing people with his lies.
It's unfortunate.
He's not the smart one that we know.